heads up guys my name is Jonah welcome
back to the code review of a game about
a flying dog that we started a while ago
I suggested in the last episode of this
kind of code review which is this video
over here that I should maybe break it
up into different topics and you guys
seem to like it so here we are the new
code review okay so what should we look
at today I think if we go back to like
game.cpp so yeah last episode we
obviously looked at
um I think I just noticed the fact that
a lot of these variables were being
passed by const reference and that
wasn't really necessary because we can
just pass them by value like that
they're pretty small four bytes and I
think a good thing today maybe to talk
about is like what on Earth is going on
here because this is uh
interesting this is ah this is such a
mess like just rating this is making me
upset why are these comments indented
okay so I'm just gonna kind of go
through this
um and like we'll clean it up and we'll
organize it as we go so first of all if
you know me you know that I don't like
to have the private stuff first
um I used to do that I used to do that
because I think ultimately I used to do
that because back in Java in the Java
days because for those of you don't know
I started with Java you'd kind of have
you know your public class game or
whatever and then you know if this is
Java code pretend and then you have like
you know private ins you know whatever
here and then you'd have like maybe some
public functions
right this is me writing Java code so
that kind of makes sense right because
you you kind of everything's in this
class and usually you put your variables
at the top it would be weird to put them
at the bottom but in C plus plus because
we have header files what I prefer doing
is because that header file is
ultimately like you can look at it as
like a representation of like what that
class provides like what is this class I
think a better way to put this is maybe
kind of like what can this class do for
me and obviously when you look at a
class like when you're not writing the
actual functionality of the class but
when you're just using the class which
ultimately like that's what happens in
programming especially if you're working
in a team with like a lot of people
you're usually like using a whole range
of different kind of functions and
you're using other people's code and
other people's apis that they've written
you're working on your own features but
you're not necessarily drilling into
every like class that you encounter and
changing stuff in it or at least you
probably shouldn't be and so because of
that it makes sense to me like if I was
to open up any class like this I want to
see what it can do for me like like I
want to see like you know what can this
class do and obviously when you look at
a class and the first thing you see is
all of this private code it kind of just
it like this is like the implementation
details of how this class Works behind
the scenes that's really what like
private stuff is right because you can't
use it outside of this class it's stuff
that is like internal to the
implementation and the functionality of
that of this actual class it's almost
like a black box it should be like kind
of hidden and so by that logic if we
open up this class and we see this stuff
first and we have to scroll down a while
to see like oh these are the functions
that we can actually call to you know
use this class that's just a bit like
you know sub-optimal like I'd like to
basically be like hey you know this is
the class called game right and this is
what it can do for me that makes so much
more sense to me so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to pop this private section
down here so that's what I like to do if
we just kind of look at this you know if
I zoom out and we look at this you know
we have the public look stuff first and
then we have the private stuff now if
there are private functions which there
are not here then I would also kind of
use another private label to kind of
divide that so that I could have you
know private functions here and then the
variables are here just to kind of
enforce some kind of organization and
separation just to get the code to kind
of look cleaner is what I do and
similarly like up here if I had like
some subtype here like I don't know a
subtype or say abstract over here or
whatever I'd have that kind of separated
by public label so that it's not just
that it's just something I do to kind of
organize the code a little bit better
now a lot of these functions I can see
end in semicolons for some reason you
don't need to do this uh you do if it's
like a declaration but if it's actually
defined like this with the body then
typically like you wouldn't put this
here so that's like another thing I'm
noticing uh so you know some of this
like formatting spacing is a bit
annoying but nothing too dramatic I'm
just literally fixing this just for me
guys guess what
I have a little secret this video is
sponsored by brilliantoto why is this a
secret because brilliant.org is one of
the best places on the internet to learn
about various stem topics such as math
computer science data science they have
a large collection of really really high
quality courses on those topics if
you're new to computer science and
struggling to kind of wrap your head
around programming then they have some
really good beginner courses that will
kind of hold your hand and teach you the
basics and the thing that sets apart
brilliant is that their courses are
really visual engaging and interactive
like for example calculus calculus can
be really really difficult to just kind
of picture in your head so they'll give
you like these widgets that you can play
with so that you can visually see how it
works it's such a good way to learn and
if you're making games like this flying
dog game you'll probably want to know a
little bit of like linear algebra and
trigonometry and they have that they
have that in this kind of visual
engaging format where they'll also
continuously quiz you to make sure that
you're retaining this information and
the best part is the brilliant have a
30-day free trial so you can try out
every everything just see what kind of
courses they have see how they work for
free for 30 days just go to
brilliant.log channel link will be in
the description below and if you do go
on to like it then brilliant have been
nice enough to offer 20 off an annual
membership to the first 200 subscribers
to sign up huge thank you to brilliant
as always for sponsoring this video so a
lot of these are obviously just declared
they just have like a semicolon and
that's just saying that there's a
function called clean but the
functionality is like here right so
you've separated it but there are some
areas obviously where you've kind of
you've defined the function inline kind
of like this which just means that
you've got the actual body of the
function sitting here in the header file
lots of people ask why like how do you
decide what to do uh it used to be like
I I honestly like just full disclosure I
don't know if this is still the case but
I had heard throughout my career at EA
and everything that if you declare a
function kind of inline like this it
kind of tells the compiler like the
compiler is more likely to inline that
function I don't really see why that
would be the case I don't know if that's
just a myth I'm happy to learn something
in this kind of circumstance but
basically it's kind of like marking the
function inline which these days doesn't
really do anything like the compiler
usually doesn't it the inline keywords
used for something else which if you
guys watch my Global variables video
which I'll link up there I covered that
the inline keyword for like or a use of
the inline keyword in that video and
then of course in msvc you can do
something like force inline if you
actually want the compiler to kind of
treat that seriously and inline the
function if you don't know what inlining
functions means by the way it just means
that instead of whoever calls this
function actually like jumping to a
different part of the code so like in a
sampler you'd have like an instruction
called call which is really like just
like a jump a jump instruction pushes
like a return address to the stack jump
instruction somewhere else in the code
base and then execute the function then
jumps back to where you were all this
jumping uh you know can actually slow
down your codes quite a bit actually
you'd be surprised at just how much time
that actually takes especially if you
obviously you know your code's made a
function so you're doing it all the time
in lining means take the contents of the
function and just plop it there so
instead of having to jump somewhere else
to actually get the instructions for
that function you'll just copy those
instructions and put them here in line
so that you can just execute the
instructions along with like where you
currently are now that can increase your
binary size if you have like big
functions and you're always inlining
them then instead of jumping somewhere
else it could actually increase the size
of your binary which that could also be
an issue and slow down your code because
suddenly less instructions can like fit
onto a cache line so it's kind of a bit
of a balancing act it's like do I jump
and therefore like ruin my cache that
way or am I just do I just have too much
stuff here but of course when you have
like a one line kind of you know
function like this then it does make
sense to just kind of inline that code
and if we go into like Visual Studio
settings here and even look at something
like release if we go to like CC plus
optimization you can see there's this
inline function expansion which even in
the release mode is actually just set
the default usually if you want a really
fast build you change that to any
suitable and that will kind of pretend
potentially increase that binary size
but usually this will actually speed up
your code by quite a bit so that's a
little uh trick there and all of that is
because yeah inlining generally
especially like really you know small
kind of functions is a lot faster but
again that doesn't mean that you have to
declare them here necessarily that's why
I'm saying it might be a myth that like
declaring them like this is means the
compiler is more likely to be like oh
yeah that's inlineable but still if it
is just like a simple return or maybe
like a couple lines of code I generally
will just declare it in the header file
just because like this is not going to
change when thinking about whether or
not to declare things in header files
there are a few considerations to make
outside of just like what the code looks
like and that is if this code is likely
to change so for example maybe we have a
function here and we might like need to
change parts of it as soon as you change
something in a header file every single
CPP file that includes the header file
has to be recompiled because remember
header files themselves they're not sent
to the compiler instead what happens is
they get just like copied and pasted
into a CPP file so we have like game.cpp
that includes is game.h so what happens
is this whole file kind of gets copied
and pasted in place of this and that is
what your code looks like when it gets
sent to the compiler and of course this
happens recursively so like you know
game.h will include like all of these
things so they'll also be kind of put
into this and so what you end up with is
an absolutely huge file in fact if we
really want to drill deep into this I
guess it's what we're talking about
today see the funny thing is I never
know what we're going to talk about in
fact I I was sure I was going to start
by talking about like this whole mess
here and I promise we'll get to that
probably in a future video but you know
why not go deep that's the whole beauty
of this series and this new kind of
format the fact that I can go deep so
I'm really enjoying that you know I used
to play table tennis back in the day I
was quite good at it if I do say so
myself and one of my one of my favorite
shots to do would be like I would kind
of go back and then I'd like hit it
like kind of up in the edge is kind of
for fun and it would usually land like
you know if this is the edge of the
table it would land like here like you
know on the opponent's side and so I
always used to call myself Team Deep
because like you know Team Deep would
kind of just get it really deep into
their court or into their onto their
table I guess so yeah a bit of a random
story but I need to get like some Team
Deep t-shirts made or something all
right so if we go into preprocessor we
can turn on pre-process to a file I
wonder if I restart video studio if
it'll make it bigger yes it will it's
because I kind of changed scaling Midway
through this episode because I forgot
that I like to scale stuff up for you
guys so pre-process to a file if we turn
that on and I'll just do it for all
configurations then we can actually kind
of see the result of what's happening so
if we go to game.cp and I hit Ctrl F7 to
compile just that one file if I just go
to like the directory of where it would
have output that file to so remember
every one of these uh dot CPP files they
become dot obj files so if we go into
like probably here we have this game Dot
BJ file which is like the actual
compiled like machine code and then we
have this dot I file because I did the
preprocess to a file and you can see
it's like 2.25 Meg so if I drag this
into Visual Studio because it is a text
file then you'll see a file that is a
hundred and twenty three thousand lines
of code and you can see that especially
around the bottom like game you know
close music if we go back to our
game.cvp look it's here right so it's
the same code but this only has 500
lines of code this has 123 000 why
because this version that's in the dot I
file what that's done is it's
recursively gone through all of these
includes and included them and so this
is actually like this preprocess to a
file thing is really cool because it
lets you see what actually is sent to
the compiler and by the way I'm doing
this obviously in visual studio and msvc
but every compiler has this function
just need to Google it so yeah this lets
you see exactly what sent to the
compiler which is relatively useful
because not only can you kind of maybe
like figure out why things seem find in
Visual Studio but then eventually they
break when you try and compile it lets
you see like obviously everything has
been included like look at this all of
this code in fact if we go down to our
code of course when we know it was like
500 lines of code so if we just scroll
up a little bit so this is like this was
this is the beginning of our CPP file if
we go up to the very top oh I actually
included this here didn't I that's funny
but let's uh let's go back to what this
was which was just like include game dot
age control F7 this will kind of refresh
so you can see this kind of STL renderer
that's the beginning of our file and
then from here it's including stuff from
game.h and this is the header file that
you can see is pasted in and before that
it's including stuff from like the
library here the algorithm header and
that's because if we go to the header
file you can see we're including
algorithm so the point is it's kind of
including all of these files here but
what's really cool is that not only does
this kind of pre-presses to a file
obviously show you what the preprocessor
does and like all of these includes it
can also expand all of the macros that
you have right so stuff like this SDI
you need everything what is that that's
a Define and it's to Define that like
expands to basically like this or that
or that or that or that's a bit wise
auring all of these kind of things
together to create like a a value really
and you can see that's happening inside
the fsdl in it if I go back to that uh
file over here to our pre-processed file
you can see what I have here is if sdl
in it and I can see that
right this is what it's expanded to and
flags here is STL window full screen but
that's not a that's not a macro that's
an actual enum that's why it kind of
hasn't been expanded mix default format
is obviously like a macro and we can see
if we scroll down here that it's this
value over here so my point is when you
have complex macros this one's not very
complex but if you had like something
that actually was a complicated macro
and you just had no idea what it expands
to and it's very difficult to debug
sometimes when you're writing macros and
you're trying to I don't know do some
kind of fancy like variatic macros where
they have like a variable amount of
arguments and you're not sure if it's
quite expanding correctly I remember
when I was writing Hazel and I was doing
like the logging kind of library for
that as well as like asserts and stuff I
wanted them to be able to take in no
arguments potentially so I could just
you know log like a blank line or
something if I wanted to or they could
take in just a string or they could take
in a string and then a bunch of
parameters that get injected kind of
into that string so it was kind of
difficult to do that just like in my
head and try and compile it as a
compiler or what is it exactly but with
this preprocess to a file I can actually
kind of see what that code is being
generated into I can see what the macro
has become so yeah that's my little tip
of the day I guess the pre-process to a
file very very useful stuff but of
course game.h you know it's included
into a bunch of different places
and actually here's another tip I'm just
full of tips today if we go into here
and maybe like all options uh and I'll
just type in include here there's this
thing called show includes now I don't
know exactly where okay it's in advanced
so CS people has advanced so show
include so if I turn that to yes and
again I'll just go back into game.cpp
let me actually turn the pre-process to
a file off so it's in preprocessor just
do no if I do control F7 then now you
can see I actually get like this huge
list which let me just dock this over
here so it doesn't interfere with the
FaceCam maybe even over here you can see
I get like I'm compiling this one file
and it's telling me what it's including
and also the the level that is being
included at so you can see like the way
that this indents is it depends like you
know it's saying that game.h like this
file includes game.h and game.h includes
this file and then this file sdl
includes sdl main which includes sdl you
know standard ins in Inc standard in C
whatever.h you can kind of see like the
whole hierarchy of includes here which
is actually really really useful when
you have like errors because of like
your include order or because of
recursive includes if somehow down the
line you're trying to compile a file and
it includes something and it's not meant
to include something so again another
example from Hazel is we support
multiple different rendering backends so
I have like Vulcan we used to support
both Falcon and opengl but that kind of
Vulcan code should never be included by
any client application so basically
Hazel at its core like the core engine
that's allowed to use Vulcan but then
like you know the Hazel run time which
is like the actual game application or
hazelnut which is the level editor that
doesn't even have Vulcan like the Vulcan
header files in its include paths like
it it can't be there which is why if we
do include something that uses Vulcan
we'll get a compile error because it
will tell us that hey I can't find
vulcan.h because it's not kind of in
that module because it shouldn't be like
that should be hidden away and
abstracted Away by like the Hazel core
kind of library and so sometimes that
will happen and it'll be like you know
what how why on Earth what's include
what what could possibly be using like
you know a Vulcan file or whatever that
we might have inside Hazel inside a
place where it shouldn't be but with
this it's really easy to just be like
all right so I know this is being
included but where is it being included
from oh I can easily just kind of trace
this down and see that like oh okay you
know for example if this like Windows
kit thing was like let's say it was a
Vulcan code I could be like oh okay it's
STL platform that's what includes this
stuff and that's not allowed to so this
kind of show includes thing is also
really really useful but the reason why
I brought it up here is because it kind
of lets us just see potentially you know
what includes game.h now in this case
not quite because obviously I'm
compiling game.cp and I'm just seeing
what is included inside game.cbp but
another quick and dirty way to just
quickly see oh let me just move this
output back to quick to to quickly and
easily see like what is actually
including a specific header file like
game.h is you can just stick an arrow in
it so if I just do hash error LOL or
something right I compile everything
then uh let me let me turn off uh show
you includes because it's gonna pollute
my um it's gonna pollute my output
window
you can see how many lulls I get right
so I got a lot of lulls there
let's dock this in here again maybe I'll
take the output as well
so you can see that in the error list
which just parses the output I have five
lulls and then over here in output I
also have my five laws and I can
actually see well actually the analyst
might even be better no it's just
because it's in game.h but in output I
can kind of send this can be difficult
because if you're doing like if you're
compiling in parallel it might be
difficult to see but you can see
bird.cpp includes must include this I
actually don't know if this is going to
build in parallel or not but whatever
game.cp includes game.h game intro
includes game game.h game outro and Main
right so these things all seem to
include game.h in some way or another
they couldn't like some other header
file might include it but the point is
because these are all sent to the
compiler as kind of individual CPP files
that's why I get this error five times
because it's trying to obviously
independently from anything else is
trying to compile this one file which
you know bird.cvp which if we look that
up
you can see that yeah that does include
game.h so my point in saying all of this
is that that's one downside that you
have to consider when you do write a
function here that if I do actually
change something like oh this actually
needs to be true or whatever then
suddenly I have to recompile like this
header file has obviously changed so
every CPP file that includes that header
file in one way or another now needs to
be recompiled and that can be annoying
because that will just make your build
times larger whereas obviously if I had
just been like okay this is going to be
now declared over here sure that's not
going to change I'm not going to change
the signature of this function or the
name or something but the contents of
its body which are now obviously
in-game.cpp that's a CPP file so just
that one kind of file that one
translation unit needs to be recompiled
and the header file that doesn't like
you know not all of these so instead of
recompiling five CPP files I'm
recompiling one CPP file which will just
make your build times faster so that's
why uh you know it's nice not to do this
but again you know I would say if it's
something like this you know and it's
like like this this is not going to
change really like return end and it's
kind of clear to see what it is and it
doesn't make this more and like maybe
it'll be more likely to be inlined
although I that's a weird thing I I have
to look that up and I'll try to quite
buy that you know for something like
player in it I would definitely
basically cut that out and then I can
just quickly use visual assist here you
can use um Visual Studio as well by the
way I don't even know what it is but
there's a quick actions and refactorings
create definition right so that's the
visual studio way of doing it so if I
now go to that just a bit annoying I
think I like visual sis version more
um then I can just paste that in
obviously now
um let's go ahead and
straighten this out oh it was just one
line of code I guess but it was there
for some reason
okay so that's the one line of code now
it's here uh and we've moved that there
now of course if anything changes like
maybe I move this to a different
directory I don't have to recompile the
files again not that it's a huge deal to
recompile those files like sure it might
be like three seconds instead of one
second to build everything right it's
not going to make a huge difference but
obviously this is just a habit that is
important because sometimes like you
know for me like sometimes if I change a
header file in Hazel I might have to
wait over a minute to get that to
rebuild especially if it's something
that might be included by like a
pre-compiled header anyway it can get
like in a large project it can get
really annoying to obviously do this
which is why I like it's really good in
C plus bars to just get into the habit
of not doing everything inside header
files but instead like using those
implementation files they're kind of
there for a reason um so yeah these are
most okay the other thing I would say is
obviously for like functions that just
return values like this and especially
if they copy it and not like return it
you know by reference like this uh make
sure you mark them as const and what
that does is it just means that if you
have a const game object somewhere so
you've passed a game by const reference
for example then you can still call this
function whereas if it's not const then
you can you can you won't be able to
call it because the copy of game you
have is const so therefore stuff that
modifies game you know for example this
this writes two games memory by setting
end to false this can't be const and
therefore you wouldn't be able to call
you know set ended uh set ended false
and you can see if I add const here
it'll tell me it's an error because it's
not modifiable unless a little cheat
here is unless you make it mutable so if
you make this mutable then you can see
over here that now I can actually set
and to false which is a little bit weird
but that's again because you you've made
it mutable you've made it changeable so
that's like a little uh cheat thing uh
why does that exist and why is it useful
probably a topic for another video but
usually I like to do that if there's
something that is like auxiliary I guess
to what I'm to what the function's meant
to be doing then that might be like an
appropriate use of that keyword but
anyway we'll get into that later
anything else here on the topic of
header files there's also some weird
stuff over here like you know there's
all these functions and then amongst
them there's like this static public you
know STL renderer thing so what I like
to do with that is I would cut that out
of this so that again the functions are
kind of first and then under here I'd
make another public label and just put
that here and of course like you know in
my convention this might be like s
rendra or if it is actually public like
this and I'll probably capitalize it
that might conflict with a class name
though and especially some other
compilers and SBC is usually fine with
that even if you you know had something
like this it would kind of just say that
that's the variable name that's the type
name but other compilers like client GCC
might not be happy with that so you have
to be careful but otherwise if it was
Private then I would call it something
like s underscore Android the S standing
for static of course okay so that I
think is pretty good next time we're
going to look at this disaster and how
we can rewrite this probably uh to just
make it look better and probably I'm
expecting the implementation side of
things uh is probably also like a little
bit difficult to deal with yeah like
there's you know all this looping
through all this kind of stuff and like
maybe there's some things we can do to
kind of improve that code because I'm
just thinking this isn't probably not
the best thing to do anyway I hope you
guys enjoy this code review if you did
please don't forget to hit a like button
I like to make these code review videos
as kind of like a just a let's talk
about code it's like a discussion so if
you guys have anything to add then
definitely leave a comment below don't
forget to check out
and I will see you next time goodbye